at Journey's End after a dangerous
ordeal at sea
migrants leave a British border Force
vessel after being rescued off the coast
of France
dozens of boats trying to reach the UK
got into difficulties in strong currents
they were in trouble there was the
problem of seasickness and then also the
boats are quite simply overloaded they
overload them and so the boats can no
longer move forward the last boat we
were intervened was twofold
for some the rescue came too late a
vessel capsized and six people were
found in the water in a serious
condition
one was airlifted to hospital in Calais
but pronounced dead soon after the other
five it was later confirmed also died
a Lifeboat and Coast Guard rescue teams
left the port of Dover at around 4am
local time after receiving a distress
signal from off the coast of sangat near
Dunkirk on the French Coast dozens of
people were rescued but the deaths again
highlight the dangers of Crossing this
short body of water between France and
the UK
French Authority said later on Saturday
that all six deceased were Afghan men as
Elway barville Secretary of State in
charge of the sea arrived to meet
Rescuers in Calais
Ed
Civic team if we mourn six victims today
it is the fault of traffickers criminals
who sent Young People women adults to
their death through these Maritime Roots
which are dangerous and deadly Home
Secretary UK Home Secretary swella
bravaman has used those dangers to
condemn The traffickers Who organize
migrant Journeys across the channel
she says her thoughts and prayers are
with those affected by Saturday's
tragedy
but as she continues to impose tough
measures against arrivals on small boats
critics say the fault lies were the
government for failing to provide safer
routes for people to seek asylum in the
UK
Al Jazeera Dover
foreign